heads up guys my name is China welcome
back to the code review series holiday
edition I'm uh currently in Germany so
we'll see how this goes in this special
holiday edition of the code review
series
um I'm gonna take a look at my own code
so recently I made a video networking in
simple spot I'll have it linked up there
so you can check it out and for that
video I made an application in C plus
plus using my Walnut framework called
Walnut chat it's like an instant
messaging kind of chat application you
know kind of like the hello world for
networking so I didn't quite have enough
time to talk about the code and look at
it kind of deeply in the networking in C
plus plus videos so I thought I'd just
do a code review so we can take a look
at it I'll show you guys how it works uh
obviously a code review traditionally is
someone else looking at someone else's
code so this is um not standard but I
have done it before I've done it for
hazel I'll have the Hazel code revealing
top there so for these kind of self I
guess auto code reviews I generally go
through it and kind of talk about the
design decisions I've made why I've
written the code of seven way just
explain how it works and also try and
criticize it because I know never
claimed that any code that I've written
is perfect there's always room for
improvement so that's what we're going
to talk about today so the link to this
Walnut chat repository will be in the
description below of course it's
completely open source you can download
it uh there's actually a release over
here which you can take a look at so if
you just want to kind of run the client
connect to the server which is chat to
other channel.com you can do that as
long as the server is running and no
one's crashed it yet um otherwise if you
want the source code just do a recursive
clone of this repository and that will
take you to this this is what it looks
like now all of my repositories I say
this a lot when I kind of I guess
criticize other people's setups for
their kind of projects but generally
with all of my projects uh one of like
the the top requirements is it has to be
easy to just build and run so let me
demonstrate what something like that
might look like once we've climbed the
repository this is what the root of the
repository looks like I just go into
scripts and you can see there's a
setup.bat for Windows and a setup.sh for
Linux because this does in fact support
Linux in kind of a headless
configuration which we'll talk about out
later in this video so if I just double
click on setup.bat that's all I have to
do you can see it will run pre-make
it'll generate all of the visual studio
2022 Solutions and projects so there are
actually two solutions one for just
Walnut chat which is like the GUI one
and then Walnut chat headless as well
once I've done that I can just double
click on this and once that opens I can
either hit F5 or just press this local
Windows debugger up here to compile
everything and run it and specifically
app client as you can see is the default
startup project so if I wanted to run
the app server instead I could you know
set it as a startup project or just run
it kind of through this so This Is It
building that's it it's running that's
all you have to do and then you can type
in your name you can pick a color go
with orange and then chat.thechannel.com
is the kind of default server but you
can enter any IP address any kind of
hostname along with like a port so feel
free to host the server yourself if you
want and then hit connect and there we
go
um and you can see we can scroll up see
the message history uh and yeah that's
um you know hello no one else currently
online because I actually just had to
restart the server crashed all right
sweet so now let's take a look at the
code and I'll talk a bit about how this
project is organized in the first place
so I feel like really the architecture
of the project starts with just looking
at the root repository we have several
different projects which you can also
see here in Visual Studio but we also
have two different solutions Walnut chat
is as I mentioned the kind of GUI
applications so aside from having this
app client we also have app server which
I can just quickly build and run here
and you can see that it I mean I've
started a server now but this is
completely GUI I can type here hello so
the server also kind of has you know the
ability to talk I can see what clients
are connected here if I wanted to by the
way what I could do is start another
instance of my app client let's just uh
make sure we have the server running
here as well
um and then instead of you know
connecting to chat.train.com which I
showed earlier I can just do
127.0.0.1 for localhost and then the
poor which is 8192 hit connect and you
can see now that I have connected over
here into this server that I am actually
running here and I can see this the
service Hello message which I sent
earlier and I can type in some chat
message obviously and you can see that
it all appears with both the server
running locally and and the actual
client as well so this is the kind of
GUI version of the server now there is
also this headless solution so if I open
the Headless solution that lets us run
the exact same server code but instead
of having a GUI we can just run it as
like a command line application like a
console application why would we want
this well if we're trying to run this on
like a Linux server for example we're
not going to have any kind of GUI and
certainly not a Windows GUI it's
possible obviously for your server to
have a GUI and in that case feel free to
run the GUI version but if you just have
like a regular VPS like a web server
then you're probably not going to have a
GUI there and besides it'll probably be
easier for you to just ssh in and just
be able to run any kind of commands you
want through a command line so that's
what this is for you can see we have app
server headless so if we just run that
then you can see actually that it's it's
running from the same working directory
so it's actually loaded the message
history that we just made we have the
server saying hello me saying hello
local server we're now listening on Port
8192 2 I can go back to the GUI version
the GUI client run that and then here I
have the server obviously here I have my
GUI client with all my settings let's
just go ahead and connect again you can
see that I'm here and I can say hi there
it is and hi from headless server and
there it is right so it's the exact same
application but just instead of having a
UI it's completely just command line and
I can also run some commands here like
kicking myself now before we jump in and
start taking a look at all this code if
computer science is something that you
maybe are just beginning and you want
some help there's an excellent freeway
you can do that with a sponsor of
today's video brilliant.org now
brilliant.org is an amazing website
filled with lots of courses on various
stem topics they have some really really
nice kind of beginner computer science
courses they'll kind of hold your hand
and guide you through like learning how
to think like a programmer which is
obviously really really important but
for those of us who might be a little
bit past that a little bit more advanced
I personally really love brilliant.org
for its math courses and really from the
beginning like from this everyday math
course which again is kind of like that
gentle introduction hand-holding kind of
I have no idea what I'm doing and I'm
scared all the way up to like linear
algebra and calculus you know we've been
using that stuff in the ray tracing
series and Brilliant specifically makes
learning this stuff like really fun the
fact that all of their courses are like
super Visual and interactive and
engaging like you can play with these
widgets to see how numbers translate
into visual things they'll quiz you to
make sure that you're paying attention
and actually learning all of that just
makes it such a good experience and such
an effective way to learn now the best
thing about brilliant is you can get
started for free they have a 30-day free
trial that you can use to just check out
the entire platform go through their
courses see if you like them and if they
do work for you and you do go on to like
them then brilliant have been nice
enough to offer the first 200 people 20
off an annual membership just go to
brilliant.org the Cherno and check it
out for yourselves huge thank you as
always to brilliant for sponsoring this
video okay so now that we've covered
like you know actually really using this
stuff and how it all comes together and
how it all works let's take a look at
the kind of project architecture a
little bit so we have at the core of
this walnut walnut is an application
framework that I made we won't talk much
about Walnut in this video but I've got
plenty of other videos on the channel
about walnut walnut networking is an
optional module for Walnut which
provides networking functionality and
that's what I want to focus on in this
video because it's probably the most
important part of this chat app app
common is a static Library which
contains the common functionality needed
by app server and app client which are
our two executables that come out of
this so let's start by talking about the
Walmart networking project and API
basically I just wanted an easy way to
spin up a server and a client and like
handle the messaging between the two and
I guess technically more than two
because you can have as many clients as
you want and by easy I just mean I
wanted the API to be straightforward and
Simple and Clean often what I like to do
is boil everything down to like its most
simple form because I feel like at the
end of the day what we're trying to do
here is not really that complicated and
to be clear when I say not complicated
I'm not talking about like the back end
kind of technical details those can be
quite complicated of course I'm talking
about like the kind of front-end API I
always like to have a good kind of high
level clean simple way of doing things
kind of like a scripting language would
be for a game engine the game engine
itself can obviously be extremely
complicated behind the scenes but maybe
I just want to like I don't know render
my character or make him move somewhere
or I don't know turn a light on like I
don't need to know all of the math
behind how the light makes the pixels
change color I just want to be like
light on please that's it now this kind
of approach can definitely have some
downsides because obviously like the
depth of this API and what you can do
with it would end up being potentially
limited but I'm a big fan of just
iterating over the API expanding it if
you need that extra functionality
because that's the thing with code like
it's not like I don't know a building
that you're constructing where you can't
just go out and rip out the foundation
and make make it better in the future
code is malleable code is easily
changeable so I like to keep the first
iteration usually really simple now just
a little side note here that's not to
say that code is always easy to change
sometimes if you make the core just bad
then you're in for some work but my
point is you're still kind of obviously
considering what this is going to be
used for and building something that you
think will more or less cover everything
you need but you're just kind of more at
the simple end of things rather than
trying to over engineer it and then
potentially just wasting time and making
the end result needlessly complicated
which is just not a good thing so that's
kind of what Walnut networking is now it
uses valve's game networking sockets API
to do all of the actual networking as I
mentioned earlier in this video I made a
video called networking NC plus plus
which is linked up there that video
covers what valves like game network
sockets library is so in this video
we'll specifically just talk about
Walnut networking's API and how it uses
valves API so so here we kind of see
what it is again it's really simple at
the moment really the meat here I guess
is client and server we have these two
classes the premise is just super simple
like I would like to start a server on a
particular Port that is capable of like
you know listening to data to that Port
now in order to actually accept data we
need to establish like a client
connection first so of course the server
is going to handle that as well so you
can see how it's already starting from a
simple idea but then it's expanding a
little bit more here it's gone from just
the server can receive data to okay the
server accepts a client connection
obviously has to manage that client
connection including the eventual
disconnection and then whilst that
client is active it can receive data
from that client and then of course also
send data to that client and really
that's all the server is now the client
is the thing that connects to a
particular server so it establishes a
connection and then whilst that
connection is active it's capable of
both sending data to that server and
also receiving data from that server and
that idea already is basically like the
core kind of layer which is basically
all we need in order to achieve our goal
of just simply data transfer between
like two Network nodes and then we also
have like these kind of networking
utilities which is just a bunch of
utility functions that may be useful for
kind of networking related tasks so
let's dive in and take a look at what
exactly is in this kind of server header
file and we'll basically just talk about
this kind of server and client API so
already I can see something here that I
don't like and that is this so you can
see that we're including this actual
game networking sockets API header files
within our own header file and really
Walmart networking is supposed to be
kind of like a black box API project I
don't know basically what that means is
that the implementation details should
be hidden by having these header files
inside one of our header files that
means that when we include this header
file which is supposed to be kind of
like a publicly accessible header file
meaning if we want to obviously you use
this server API and start a server using
wallet networking inside like one of our
apps then we obviously have to include
this header file which means we also
include steams kind of you know game
network is like I said I should really
just call it gns or something it's
getting annoying to say uh we need to
include these gns like API header files
and what does that mean that means that
these projects like app server and app
client that include you know server.h I
mean really the server is probably the
only app including a server.h but if it
does sends these also are included that
means that this stuff needs to be in the
include path for these projects I don't
want that I just want us to be able to
add Walnut networking and that is it we
shouldn't then also have to make sure
that these header files are accessible
because that's supposed to be kind of
like the internal API it's the exact
same concept as Vulcan in Hazel we don't
want the actual like game executable
project to have to even know what Vulcan
is because Vulcan might not be the
rendering API that is used why should we
have to like look up the Vulcan SDK and
like find the appropriate header files
make sure they're in the kind of
compiler include path for our game
project that should all be handled by
the actual engine and abstracted away
and so that's why this is bad now how
would we fix something like that well
it's pretty simple to fix really because
if you take a look at this I mean why is
it even included what are we using
inside this header file specifically
that needs those header files and really
as far as I can see it's just stuff like
this steamnet connection status change
callback which this is a pointer which
means it's really really easy to just
get rid of that and then we have this
htmnet connection which that itself is
just a un-32 right so we have basically
an unsigned integer and then a pointer
so far which is obviously very easy to
remove in fact I'll show you guys how to
remove it in a minute and then we have
like this H steam lesson socket which
also is a un-32 and then we have this
poll Group which is also a un-32 so as
an example how would we get rid of this
well let's first get rid of this I'm
going to paste it into the CPP file
because that of course does need to know
what these are what I'm trying to do
here obviously is not get rid of this
entirely that would make sense like this
wouldn't work without that I'm just
trying to remove it from the header file
because the header file is a thing that
is included in other modules and other
projects the implementation file the cpb
file that is just part of this Walnut
networking static library and that is
the only thing that should actually
contain this so in other words all the
CPP files inside the Walnut networking
project are free to include this stuff
it's just the public facing headers that
really should not and by public facing
I'm just talking about headers that can
be included into our actual like users
of this API so the other projects that
want to use will not networking and
actually as soon as we do that we can
just hit Ctrl F7 to just try and build
this file we'll get a whole bunch of
errors here obviously because now none
of these uh you know things that we were
using uh actually knows like what type
it is but now we can just simply go back
and fix all of this so H steam
connection and what is that that's just
the un32t now usually in these cases I
don't even really bother trying to like
Define this or deal with it I just fall
back to the actual time right so H seam
connection is a un32t so I can literally
just change this to be you and 32t is
this like the safest thing to do not
really because if the API ends up either
conditionally defining that type which
we know in this case it doesn't it's
always a un32 but in the future if it
just happens to change it that might be
bad uh but otherwise all it really is
doing is we're just kind of taking away
the semantics of what that means right
so HD Net Connection that's like a bunch
of English words that are a little bit
more descriptive than just the un32t and
so when we kind of use this over here we
know that this is a map of specifically
these kind of connected clients but you
can see we are actually applying our own
meaning here so what I would probably do
if I needed to rewrite this code is I'd
write something like this and then I
would just be like you know originally
this in gns API so that way we know like
what this is really is at its core we
can refer to the gns like documentation
if we need to but we're going to treat
it as client ID because that's kind of
what it's being used at it's it's this
kind of Net Connection identifier that
is just a un-32t so if we go down here
that means that again instead of just
changing you know this to be a unit 32t
for our connector clients might as well
make it be our type that we defined
because client ID makes more sense than
you and 32t even though of course to the
computer they're completely equal um
okay so we have this interface and then
we have let's just do the easy ones
first so we have this kind of listen
socket and poll group now listen socket
that's just the socket that we're
listening on honestly I don't feel like
this needs to be anything other than a
u132t like I don't need to make like a
using socket uh just socket or something
you know like it's just going to be a
number between I think zero and six by
five through five or something right so
I can still limit it to 16 bit are they
I don't know maybe I'll look that up um
and then Paul group now Paul group could
be a little bit more interesting uh but
you know I could do a similar thing here
where I just say that this is basically
this but I'm making it a un32t and by
the way just to be clear because this is
literally a human 32t these two types
are completely compatible because again
they're just kind of fluff that is added
onto C plus blast to make it more human
readable at the end of the day what is
it it's a four byte unsigned integer
that is it okay and then we have
something a bit more interesting here we
have this which is actually a class
however it's a pointer whenever you have
something that is a pointer you have to
realize that this part of it I'm going
to zoom in here this part of the pointer
yeah so here's my this is my pointer
this part of it that I have kind of in
this red rectangle is completely
meaningless that part has nothing to do
with the actual data storage or the type
itself that is again purely for you as
the human to make it a little bit easier
to deal with this type remember what is
a pointer the video on pointers and C
plus plus check it out a pointer is just
an integer that contains the memory
address of well I don't know what really
it's just it just contains a memory
address it's an integer that is a memory
address it's typically 64 bits because
we compile our code in a 64-bit
architecture but it could be 32 bits if
you're compiling it with a 32-bit
architecture but these days in 2023
pretty much all the stuff we build here
on PC is going to be 64-bit so therefore
it's just an 8 by 64-bit integer and
that is it doesn't matter if it's an ice
team networking sockets or an INT or a
void you know you can have a void
pointer does that matter absolutely not
it's just an integer which is the memory
address so then what is this type used
for it helps us be able to use that
pointer in a more kind of meaningful and
straightforward way so for example if it
is a type then by accessing it through
an arrow we can get to either the data
members or the functions that are part
of that type if it's an integer then we
know that an integer is four bytes so if
I do something like pointer plus plus
it's going to advance four bytes forward
if it was a Char pointer instead then
pointer plus plus would only Advance one
byte so it kind of gives this like extra
functionality as far as the language
goes as far as C plus plus goes to the
computer again doesn't matter the data
type itself is just going to be an
integer which holds the memory address
so what does that tell us that tells us
that this again might as well be a void
pointer now if we do make this a void
pointer though and we start dealing with
this it means that every time we
actually want want to use interface for
its API meaning I want to call this
function for example that is part of
this class we have to cast it to that
class I don't want to do that so instead
what I can do is I can forward declare
that type but that means that I don't
know what this type is at this point but
I will later and to do that all we have
to do is just type in class and then the
name like that with a semicolon so
there's no body there's no definition
here it's just a declaration of that
class now the compiler will yell at you
if you get struct and class mixed up so
usually what I like to do is just
actually you know go to this class and
be like okay is it a class is it a
struct it's a class good I'm going to
use it as a class is it part of a
namespace no not in this case so
therefore it needs to be outside
obviously of your namespace and just in
nowhere you can also declare it within
here but then you have to make sure that
you kind of get rid of any namespaces by
just doing something like that but of
course that's just adding extra code so
I would just pop it over here so what
does that let us do that lets us
actually retain this type now we want to
to be able to use it like if you're
trying to instantiate a class of this
type and all you have is a forward
declaration that won't work because of
course how does the compiler know what
function to call you know what
Constructor to call what members to like
you know set up and how much memory even
to allocate if the type is not defined
so you will have to eventually Define it
but again we're not using it here we're
just declaring it as an actual pointer
so we know already that it has eight
bytes of data storage to hold this
pointer within our kind of server class
here and then when we actually start
using it somewhere here like we call new
or in this case I think we call this
function to retrieve that kind of class
instance pointer Whatever by then we
need to be able to you know have the
actual definition which is contained in
these headers that we do in fact include
now it is worth noting that if this had
not been a pointer this would not work
because if we have something like this
then what are we doing here by calling
this code like this we are actually
trying to instantiate the class and it
doesn't know what the class so that's
not going to work so this only really
works for pointers okay um if we come
back up here let's see well let's just
try and compile this we'll see what else
we're missing here it's definitely less
now uh okay age steam Net Connection
which is again our client ID so let's go
ahead and include client ID here
um over here as well which this is set
client Nick we've still got age
connection I think that's probably from
some of their example code so we can
actually rename this to just be like
client ID and then I'll do the same over
here as well client ID and that lets us
set a connection name here which is
useful for debugging
uh and then we have these steam uh Net
Connection status change callbacks which
is functions but again bit just pointers
so what can we do we can look at what
they are and you can see they're just
structs so now what I'll do is I'll take
this I'll copy it and I'm gonna put it
over here so now we have a class and a
struct and that's all we need to do for
this let's go back to the CVP file hit
controller 7 to compile just that file
and that's it you can see that our
project now built successfully so what
have we done here we've taken the header
files out of this header file and we've
moved it into the zbp file and
everything still functions as you would
expect with the primary benefit being
now you know app server or app client
our kind of executable projects which
use Walnut networking now no longer need
that game networking sockets API header
files to be in the include path anymore
it doesn't have to know anything about
the gns API whatsoever it just knows
well not networking and that's enough
for it uh and obviously we'd have to do
the same thing like for client because
client does that as well but I'm not
going to do that here in this video now
I would also probably just you know
write a little message here being like
four declarations for gns API just so
that it's clear you know where these
even come from even though I mean it
does say it's team networking sucks
literally and steam Net Connection
change so you kind of get the point but
I'd still have it up there all right
cool so we did a little bit of like
actual code reviewing here which is good
um if we just take a look at the API
which again good news is simple so this
shouldn't take too long all you really
have to do here is just instantiate this
object with a port instantiating it does
nothing so if we're trying to create a
server here we just type in a port like
8192 that's kind of my go-to port number
we then can literally just start the
server and we're ready to go but if we
want to be notified of certain events
such as like I want to be able to you
know be notified if I receive data or a
client connects then we have these
functions which is just simply callback
functions that we can just set and then
whenever something happens that callback
function will be called with whatever
parameters it needs aside from that we
can obviously do just send data to a
client whether it be a string or more
commonly just a buffer and a buffer is a
walnut buffer which is just taken from
Hazel or hazelbuffer it's just a wrapper
over like a void pointer it's also got
its size with a bunch of utility
functions that just makes it easier to
kind of deal with raw pointers which are
intended to be buffers of memory uh we
can send it reliable or unreliable which
at the end of the day just basically
will call you know send a message to
connection from that gns API with either
the reliable or unreliable flag so
unreliable might be good for things like
I'm a here game and I'd like to you know
transmit like the player's location
which if I miss a few frames like that's
okay but reliable might be something
like a chat message or I'm trying to try
and download some data obviously I want
that no matter what so if it fails to
send it or whatever resend it and then
what else do we have here we've got some
templated versions here just so that we
can kind of instead of sending a buffer
or a string here we can just send any
templated type so I could send an INT I
could send a struct that is kind of
trivial meaning it doesn't contain like
you know inaccessible will kind of
directly data like pointers to other
blocks of memory and then for all of
these variants we also have the tool
clients version with an optional client
that we'd like to exclude so this is
really useful for that Walnut chat
application for example because if I
receive a message from a client and I
need to send it to all the other clients
except for the client that just sent me
that message I can just call one of
these functions and then we can also
kick the client so if we quickly take a
look at what it means to actually start
this server once you call server start
it will actually create a new network
thread then it will kind of initialize
the game networking sockets API here
it'll retrieve this like instance of the
version essentially of the API I would
like to use because it might involve
steam it might not involve steam it
might be a particular version whatever
we now have an API that we can use to
create like this lesson socket IP
meaning we're going to be listening on
that port create something called a poll
Group which just lets us more
efficiently kind of handle groups of
clients and like you know receive data
from all of them send data to all of
them that kind of stuff this should
definitely be replaced with low loss
logging which gives us stuff like you
know colors and time stamps and logging
to files as well as the console but I
don't think that's quite ready yet in
Walnut so I ended up just using C out
for now but that should be replaced
here's our main kind of running Loop
remember this is on a separate thread
this is on our networking thread we'll
just poll incoming messages which as the
name implies we'll just try and receive
messages from that poll group and then
if a message is received and we validate
that we actually have you know a
registered client sending us that
message and we didn't somehow mess up or
miss something then if that message has
a size that is not zero we'll call this
data received callback so that you know
whoever hooks up to that event can
actually be notified of the data that we
receive which we then also kind of
transform into this Walnut buffer so
that it's easier so that it's easier to
deal with we then do this poll
connection State changes is really
really important this will just call run
callbacks which will basically call this
big juicy function called on connection
status change this is important it's
quite a quite a lot of code as well this
is needed to actually handle the state
of connections so when a client tries to
connect it goes down to this connecting
thing and then we basically have to try
and accept the connection if it fails
we'll do this we'll try and set a
connection poll group for that
connection as well uh then we'll
retrieve some connection info which we
can use just for like you know debugging
really and just a little bit more
information about that connection we'll
register the connected client by just
adding it to this map of all of our
clients and set aside data what it needs
to be the ID is obviously important if
we want to both kind of manage that
connection but also send data
specifically to that client we need the
client ID so we store that and then
we'll call the client connectors
callback with this probably should be
set though like as in we probably should
test that to make sure that like it's
not just null because this obviously is
just an STD function and that can kind
of be null which I think in the current
version of the library at least means
that it will probably crash or something
so I think that's just nervous eye it
needs to be behind an F I believe this
code review is already paying off um and
that's kind of it now if we like you
know disconnect or whatever that happens
here like if it's closed by peer meaning
the client wants to disconnect and it is
currently connected then we can
obviously call a client disconnected
callback remove it from our Client List
do all that kind of stuff uh and then
just close the connection kind of
cleanly so that's really all all the
server does it's simple but you can see
that still like this is almost 300 lines
of code there's quite a lot abstracted
by this you can see how much code is
needed from the actual gns API that I
didn't want to write didn't want to you
know poll incoming messages start a
thread do all that stuff if I wanted a
simple server that's what Walnut
networking is for so if I look at the
actual app server project and we go to
where we create the server which is over
here you can see that this has a Walmart
uh server over here here's our Walnut
server and then what do we do we just
create it with a given Port we just set
our kind of callback functions here here
to call into member functions inside
this class and we just start the server
and that's all we have to do and then
like for example if we receive data well
let's see what that looks like this
function will just simply be called by
the Walnut server class with the client
info of who sent it and a walnut buffer
which contains like the buffer of data
that we receive and then we can just
deal with that like it's super super
simple super straightforward now the
client API is also really simple if we
just cut to the actual app client and we
take a look you can see again we just
create a client we just set up these
callbacks which do the same kind of
thing as the server and then it's not
quite as simple as doing client dot
start because obviously we need to
connect to a server and we have that
kind of UI you know modal dialog that
lets us actually type in a server
address so after that address is like
you know typed in and we want to connect
to it we'll basically call client
connect to server with that server IP
and then that you know internally will
basically start that Network thread
which will try and connect you know by
IP address to that server after like you
know pausing it making sure it's valid
and all of that kind of stuff so you can
see that does also kind of abstract
quite a bit and it makes it really
simple again the kind of Walnut client
API here is just create the client class
instance set your callbacks and then
just type in an IP address that you'd
like to connect to now before we do that
though you can see that we have some
Network utility functions which is this
kind of other class that I didn't really
talk about much yet these are just some
utilities there's basically two here
there's just is valid IP address which
we'll actually call the steam networking
utility function that will check to make
sure that we can actually parse this
string into a valid IP address meaning
like you know have you just typed in
like this or is it like properly kind of
formatted you know to be something like
this which is valid this I think
includes IPv6 addresses as well and then
we have resolve domain name because
valves game network and sockets API does
not contain any kind of way to actually
connect to a domain name and like
resolve it into an IP address it only
lets you connect to to an IP address so
we have to basically write our own
function here which in this case uses
just the win32 API and therefore we have
a different implementation depending on
the platform so for Windows you can see
this is actually tucked away into Walnut
networking platform Windows Walmart
networking and Windows networking utils
so that we only compile this on Windows
not on Linux which we also support
because of course this is just win32 API
stuff won't work on Linux and then this
is just you can see I've written a note
here that's adapted from this example
inside msdn uh and then yeah I mean this
is what it does basically just takes in
a string view name such as
chat.trainer.com and it will hopefully
give you out an IP address either like
an ipv4 or an IPv6 address which you can
then take you can see we do a little
resolve domain name here uh we'll
separate out the port as well as adding
a default Port if we didn't specify a
port and then we'll connect to that
server IP which expects to basically
have an IP address and a port in kind of
format that I typed out earlier um okay
well there's lots more really to talk
about that's like the basics I guess of
Walmart networking yeah the client I
didn't really goes thirdly through the
client as I did through the server but
it's very very similar there's still
that same on connection status change
except it's obviously a bit different
because of where the client not the
server but we still need to make sure
that we can actually successfully like
maintain that connection what happens if
the server shuts down like we should
probably be notified that the server's
gone and you can see that there's
additionally this thing called a
connection status which is disconnected
connected connecting failed to connect
and the reason why this exists is
because typically we're disconnected
meaning that we have either just made
the client instance and we haven't
connected yet or we've specifically
cleanly disconnected versus are we fully
connected and active or are we in the
process of waiting for a connection like
we've requested a connection but the
server hasn't finished that kind of
handshake to establish the connection or
have we tried but we failed and this is
really nice because like we do run this
kind of asynchronously I guess on as
Network thread for the client as well
but if we are trying to render some UI
that is like what is going on then we
can just simply query from any thread
like what the connection status is just
kind of read only here and if it is like
connecting we can be like where
currently connecting or if we failed we
can be like you failed to connect so
there's this little bit more kind of
status here and that's kind of a useful
thing that this API also provides uh all
right I think this video is dragging on
long enough there's still so much more
that I want to cover I want to cover
this whole kind of headless
configuration as well and how that fits
together as well as like the actual app
Client app server like I didn't cover
that at all so let me know if you want
to see more in the comment section below
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button as always don't forget to check
out brilliant.org the Cherno and I will
see you guys next time goodbye